Before you get started connecting your
ribber, turn it over and locate the slot
for the racking handle
and insert the racking handle.
It's easier to visualize at this point.
Later, you can insert and remove
the handle with the ribber attached.
In the manual, this is
called an auxiliary piece.
It's also known as a setting plate,
and it holds the ribber joiner in place
to join the ribber to the main bed.
Slip the setting plate
into the main bed slot as shown.
There's a right and left auxiliary piece
or setting plate.
And finger-tighten the nut,
leaving it loose.
Repeat for the other side.
Pick up the ribber and carefully insert
the joiner into the auxiliary piece
or the setting plate.
You'll be inserting both sides at the same
time, so it might be helpful to have
an extra set of hands available.
Once the ribber is in place,
tighten the screws in the setting plate.
Position the ribber joiner support leg
against your table
and secure it with a clamp.
Repeat this for the other side.
Next, rotate the pushup cam
in the direction of the arrow and be
sure that it clicks into place.
This provides extra support for the ribber.
Using both hands,
raise the ribber all the way up and confirm
that the connections are tight.
Next, you'll join the knitting
carriages and explore using your ribber.